peu
[Musique]
à
on
[Applaudissements]
c
à
dans la forme aujourd'hui à l'ats
et ben donne le meilleur journaliste
sportive de paris par ici
salut vous appelez bardol c'est exact
christophe bardol christophe victor
emmanuel bardol je peux passer
est ce que vous êtes déjà mais en
irlande en irlande aussi mais ça date
pas d'hier
avec les compliments de notre cher et
voilà de belles roses des roses rouges
les roses de du plat
désir
[Musique]
serment avoir barbouillé
on m'avait l'hymne à l'amour crise
mondiaux crise je suis venu tout de
suite était encore battu crise mais
contre un camion de béton j'ai perdu aux
points
qu'est ce que tu as mal uniquement quand
je ris d'où sortent ces horreurs mais
crise ce sont des fleurs des roses jette
les à la poubelle tu n'es plus l'hérault
ce moment je déteste les roses
je ne veux plus de rossi entend plus
jamais
[Musique]
qui était cette espèce d'abruti qui vous
a attaqué dans les vestiaires j'ai
oublié
quelqu'un peut attaquer dans les
vestiaires je me souviens pas moi non
jamais et toi absolument pas écoute
absolument pas
[Musique]
je suppose que je devrais avoir autant
de se lâcher et ça devient dangereux
quand on divise heroes mike hayes tu as
raison allez tu as là franchement jan je
suis désolé d'avoir massacré ce parti
oui moi aussi
nous aurions dû l'achevait sur place je
sais d une impulsion de timidité
ridicule j'ai vraiment honte de moi est
ce que tu es chiron moins que c'était
notre homme
après la bagarre je ne l'aurais pas juré
mais avant la bagarre j'ai été formé à
attendre pendant dix ans et se tromper
car c'était bienvenu reviennent donc sur
l'assuré t'es pas sérieux c'est
mortellement
nous allons bientôt atterrir à
l'aéroport de dublin à y attacher vos
ceintures
dis donc tu sais qu'on a déjà fait
nicolas la femelle gorille nous sommes
entre monnaies dites nous pourquoi vous
l'avez voir des messieurs soyez gentil
il a besoin de calme
est ce que c'est vrai lui a prêté un
deuxième ligne irlandais d'homosexuels
kg
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez 30 merde et
dès qu'il va sortir de l'hôpital je les
installe dans ma maison de marbella
je vais me soigner leur taper le
chouchouter et quant à moi j'ai bu j'ai
eu une grippe affreuse
il faut que je prenne un peu de repos je
tourne dans dix jours
c'est quoi le titre du film venez on va
en faire une des clippers avec ses
fleurs et voilà asseyez-vous monaco va
la chercher mais nathan la porte car
étant les mares de cirque
je me dis ça pour faire ça il ne vole
haut tu me dois combien 105 125 tu les
as tu mates en cinq minutes et j'efface
l'ardoisé des gains je te tue
les voilà
[Musique]
beaucoup vu du sang
ces marches
sur marche
attention marche
voilà pourquoi
voir ne rien mais aussi à voir
aux athées venu chercher patrick comme
tu vois c'est gênant si la voiture est
par là ouais j'y suis fière de l'état de
la chose qui m'a montré prête aux études
à la main à cette bonne vieille boîte
c'est plus sûr que tous ces gros bruit
vient à penser à l'arrière d'une wii
[Musique]
on vient à peine de ne pas y venir j'ai
tout abandonné matin madame docteur
filiol chef du service de traumatologie
professeur à la faculté
je suis tellement guo rassurez vous
madame
il n'a rien de grave quelques ecchymoses
très superficielle au cuir chevelu les
radios une addict rien de très méchant
regardez ça ne servait que je veux dire
à tous ces corps je suis ravi de ces
bonnes nouvelles
novelli oui moi aussi crise monsieur
bardol qu'est-ce que non je veux juste
voir si je pouvais encore marcher pour
l'amour du ciel crise
tu n'as rien au jour mon chéri c'est
l'athlète la tête
n'est ce pas parce que ça colle ou de
briller
[Musique]
est-ce que je te dépose chez toi à nous
ne donnons pas chez moi c'est pas
possible je suis pas seul j'ai rencontré
hier lé post hier et je laime alors vers
là qu'est ce que je vais lui dire et
puis c'est tout petits chez moi ça me
rapporte rapporte aisément fou écrase on
va chez toi j'ai à te parler tu ne
respecte même pas
[Musique]
mahé milliers on m'a cassé la gueule en
public dans les copains de foot géant je
sais même pas ce que c'est ça le voulait
crac grand kiff cas où dans une armoire
mais tu voudrais que je passe l'épongé
calme toi non non et non frappe et et
l'irlande s'il le faut mais nous les
retrouverons et nous allons faire un
massacre
nous oui toi et moi je t'emmène pas non
non non et non mille fois non
écoute moi tout va bien palmero tami en
bouillie sur la ligne de wagram qui t'a
conduit chez le toubib ces trois sites à
fait bouffer pendant des semaines
toi mais tu étais le jeu qui laisse à
régler quand avaler sabatini sur le dos
toi et les filles voient là le mérite
sportif quoi et la pension alimentaire
de ta femme parce que le seuil est ta
femme
toi qui tu as fait entrer dans le
journalisme par la grande porte
je me contente de charrier des caméras
et un pois chiche dans la tête c'était
jeanne pour moi tu n'auras pas tu
refuses gilles à shannon en irlande
jamais
les voleurs ont fait arrêter la
correspondance pour dublin on ne savait
pas envie de venir en irlande va le dire
clairement à paris vous allez environ
oui est du plateau de télé revue
j'arrive
[Musique]
je suis désolé monsieur vraiment désolé
c'est notre seule chambre des libres au
téléphone je voulais bien préciser deux
chambres la réceptionniste dû comprendre
que vous vouliez une chambre pour deux
personnes cet écrit ici monsieur et
madame bardol en fait c'est notre suite
nuptiale
vous verrez le lien très grand qu'est ce
que tu attends toi à monter bagages un
polo à cet enfant et c'est bon aller et
goûte
je pense à mes goutte c'est bon
ouais
on vient avec des baguettes vois pas
pourquoi il faudrait pas avec des
petites filles
vas-y tu chantes
et enfin paulo si j'avais eu d'histoires
de femmes dans ces mondiaux de ville je
m'en souviendrai dû y mettre les pieds
une fois dans ma vie il ya plus de dix
ans oui mais c'était pourquoi je sais
plus j'ai oublié ouais c'est en fait
qu'est ce que j'étais venu faire ici je
suis pas un match de foot de rugby de
boxe c'est plus l'ouverture de la
première maison de haute couture
irlandaise
sayah paulo je me souviens
terre rose et rose plus lourde que de la
fonte
qu'est ce que tu racontes a été sublime
d'accord qui sprinte une femme aux
épaules aux une femme une forêt femmes
j'en étais sûr ça s'est passé là en face
se souviennent tout est là au troisième
étage
c'était un lundi au printemps
c'était en retard comme d'habitude
[Musique]
c'est vraiment sortir mais qu'est ce que
vous faites là monsieur vous n'avez pas
le droit de venir ici avec cet appareil
vous inquiétez pas je n'ai pas agnel
saliès je vous en prie je m'appelle vous
aider oui je suis christophe barbe
bah oui oui voici monsieur par toi
partout
total a été près de moi je n'ai vu que
ses yeux des flaques d'eau de mer ce
prix vous m'accordez elle ne l'entendait
pas moi non plus j'étais dans la ouate
j'avais chaud partout de l'intérieur
comme une décharge électrique douce
continue brûlante
la directrice avait dû sentir qu'il
s'était passé quelque chose entre nous
je ne pouvais pas détaché mes yeux de ce
joli visage bon alors c'est vous la robe
de mariée c'est drôle chaque fois que je
vois une robe de mariée ça me donne le
fou rire nous allons commencer
si vous voulez bien regagner votre bien
sûr allez-y merci voilà
elle
paris deux fois
je tenterai jeu
souvent comme ça
bonjour mesdames et messieurs soyez les
bienvenus à notre défilé de mode numéro
1 dame de pique
une jolie veste pailletée pour le
cocktail
avec une robe courte noire à parements
de strass qui complètent l'ensemble
lila de minuit une robe du soir
monté sur une ceinture en dentelle de
valenciennes
les manches sont prises dans l'ampleur
du corsage
[Musique]
c'est le 29 mai et le 29 le programme le
final la robe de mariée
[Musique]
la robe de mariée en organza et
dentelles à manches longues et par
membre d avec un voile cours et sorties
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs au revoir merci
et alors virer la mise à la porte sur le
champ pas de poules et après deux heures
plus tard je sortais du restaurant je
t'ai vu qu'ils traversaient le rôle de
l'hôtel en asie gicler - crash et moi
dessus je ne vous en voudrez pas je suis
vraiment navré tu dois vous avouer que
j'ai bien envie dior givenchy cardin fat
vous avez peut-être une préférence à la
moue de vous et n'importe lequel vous
signe un contrat on parle tout de suite
je vous laisse une minute pour aller
chercher votre sac vous êtes descendus
dans cet hôtel irlandaises ont pour la
vè irish coffee
vous m'en voulais tellement vrai oui
alors nous avons dîné tous les deux
dommage vous avez tellement envie qu'on
se connaisse mieux moi aussi
vraiment
venez me prendre ce soir à minuit
chambre 309 je vous attendrai
4 à attendre j'étais comme un fou à
minuit précise je frappe à sa porte
ne restez pas là on me surveille votre
mari mes frères vous en avez combien 5,3
chez moi dans le kerry et deux autres
ici ils attendent devant la grande
entrée aller jusqu'à la fenêtre vous les
verrez vous me jurez de ne pas fermer la
porte
[Musique]
impressionnant votre mère les a élevées
au sein jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans je suis
vraiment désolé je m'y attendais pas une
minute
attendez une minute si je trouve un
moyen d'éloigner vos deux frères vous me
laissez ma chance j'espérais tout de
même pas les chasser à coups de fleurs
écoutez moi bien un spring vous allez
descendre dans le hall et vous cacher
près de la porte lorsque vous verrez vos
frères s'engouffrer dans l'escalier
foncé dehors d'accord mais d'après vous
qu'est ce qui pourrait le faire
s'engouffrer dans l'escalier un truc
français système d et quand vous serez
hors de l'hôtel traverser le parking est
allé au petit kiosque dans le jardin je
vous y rejoindrait très vite
dépêchez vous
[Musique]
c'est vous les cabanes 1 pourquoi
attaquer le sujet c'est tout ce que j'ai
pu arracher ce sale type quelle saleté
celui qui vient d'enfoncer la porte de
votre soeur allons-y bien chaude et
quant au volet est attendu par
l'ascenseur non on ira plus vite par
l'escalier
[Musique]
autre
je peux savoir ce que vous avez dit à
mes frères rien du tout je n'ai fait que
leur offrir des fleurs qui vous diront
ce qu'il y à une boîte dans cette ville
où l'on puisse écouter de la bonne
musique
vous savez qu'ils vont écumer tout
dublin pour me trouver vous ne sentirez
plus d'irlande vivent alors donc spain
j'ai fait le biafra le vietnam
le tremblement de terre d'agadir vous
savez vos frères voilée aller par là
[Applaudissements]
vous senti le passé je me le demande
oui ça fait envie comme l'un ce nom
je veux rentrer chez moi tout de suite
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
à
alors comme dans un rêve
nous avons dansé sur l'herbe par moment
des nappes de brume nos entouré leur
étiquette spring souriait
j'étais heureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son prix
je sens un prix non
comment
[Musique]
tout mêmes erreurs que le bel esprit
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient donc de si
différent
elle était vierge
paulo qu'est ce que tu fous dans mon lit
sa chance mais ça j'en sais rien
photo apollo 10 mois on nous sommes
allez vas-y voulez vous un peu de café
très bien c'est noté monsieur quel
numéro de chambre
la suite nuptiale je vous montre ça tout
de suite monsieur alors elle était
vierge et après après rien je suis
rentré à paris le jour suivant
l'autre chose à faire que de m'occuper
d'une irlandaise que j'avais même pas vu
en plein jour malheureusement tel qui
s'est rappelé à mon bon souvenir
or le truc classique mais sa hache à
l'agent seulement 3 moore
je suis enceinte c'était vrai et comment
tu le jeu au sol mais qu'est ce que tu
as fait tu fait renvoyer reportage au
congo à mon retour
d'autres lettres d'elle tu les as lu non
au panier après les journées vous verrez
une par mégarde il venait de l'ambassade
elle voulait que je reconnais son enfant
une obsession non mais tu te rends
compte qu'il y avait dû reconnaître tous
les enfants qu'on m'a attribué
il était vierge qui mérite avant moi
peut-être mais après tout des menteuses
ça commence dans la passion et ça finit
dans la layette non mais tu vois en
train de changer a nourri son essai doit
être merveilleux d'avoir un enfant alors
qu'est ce que tu attends toi je crois en
avoir avec la postière à jose pas et
risquerait trop de me ressembler par
contre si j'avais ton physique alors là
écoute paulo pour régler mes comptes
avec ses deux salles autres gorilles de
frère eli frère de qui et de spring de
l'irlandaise parce que tu avais pas
encore réalisé que c'est les mêmes qui
m'avait cassé la figure au parc des
princes
entrez et vous là vous avez quelque
chose à dire dites le non non
[Musique]
à
quelques huttes hier soir dublin et
maman qui nous attend est le français le
français quel français
on n'a pas eu le temps de me chercher
c'est difficile de trouver un français
en france oui en plus les français sur
cent bluetooth ou bayonne ouais
[Musique]
mon dieu on a oublié le cadeau d'anthony
google a constamment damien vidéo engage
d'accord t'as perdu
quel est le gage comme d'habitude un
baiser pourquoi on paie patrick oncle
chagnon clients ne sont pas encore là et
le probable qu'ils osent pas rentrée
après la dégelée qui sont polis vous
faites quelque chose de mal tu es trop
jeune pour comprendre
[Musique]
ça marche entre henry ça va marcher at
any je croyais avoir dit de monter dans
sa chambre et de réviser tes leçons mais
maman je veux voir le cadeau qui me
rapporte le verra ce soir au dîner s'ils
arrivent plus tard qu'il m'appellera je
t'appellerai maintenant fils je pourrais
dire quand on remet un grand père tu
pourra le dire quand j'aurai fini et
michael si on s'en faisait si tu veux
moment on peut qu'elle jouisse you sera
pas être encore au rythme arbitre
d'accord un désolé je suis occupé mais
que le meilleur gagne
[Musique]
ouais près et
salut pieters à lui les bulles match à
la télé ouais on a été vraiment minable
moussaoui à la laddh beau temps je suis
sûr que vous n'auriez fait qu'une
bouchée de ses petits français la raison
c'est pas des joueurs que nous avons
aussi vite ballerines ça c'est vrai dans
30 minutes
non bon comme vous voudrez alors à plus
tard à plus d'ardeur
pourquoi tu as du nombre un peu de
pudeur shawn la patronne du pub est une
française
notre ennemi depuis qu'elle est posée
peter elle est aussi l'irlande est ce
que nous n'enchaînons le jour du tournoi
des cinq nations doit voir le sens
patriotique
la valeur est bien une bière patrick non
non entre
[Musique]
les deux joueurs sont venus faire leurs
cours à notre soeur ce matin singer a
apporté une boîte de chocolats aux
raisins et aux noisettes avec un beau
ruban autour ça lui a plu elle en a été
ravie elle l'a donnée aux poules
et qu'est ce qui est importé organes et
lui apporter une grosse plantes à fleurs
rouges
elle l'a donnée aux vaches à ça se
termine mal elle ne se décide pas très
vite
hogan & woods singer vont s'entretuer le
plus grave c'est que nos poulets nos
vaches finiront quoi zone et je suis
bourré
[Musique]
champagne pour monsieur au jingle
hahaha
dis moi comment encore du champagne s'il
te plaît
m
merci quand même
champagne coule à flots
[Musique]
ouais hein
la lumière commun
[Musique]
ah ah
donc
à
et il voit
c'est de la baule
quand même pas moi
vidal au complet
[Musique]
j'ai présenté mes compliments à monsieur
hogan et apporter lui une nouvelle
bouteille
oui
m
une autre bouteille pour monsieur
chengere messieurs
la plupart
à
hugo mais on sent un centième chaud audi
munitions monsieur aurélie est ce que
votre établissement est approvisionné
convenablement en bon vieux whisky
irlandais sur voulez vous alors de
porter à ce gentleman un flacon de votre
meilleur vieux whisky tas
[Musique]
à
quel bonnet quoi de mieux pour effacer
les infâmes soudure d'un pays étranger
myriam tels que la terre de notre patrie
allez venez on va être en retard
saloperie bagnols maman conduit son
problème cette voiture depuis 30 ans
descendez pousser
alan j
[Musique]
amis
ali
[Musique]
bonjour
très bien dormi
[Musique]
m
une aubaine
regarde
toi
[Musique]
sa tâche est de sony c'est plus fort
pousser mais attention la route est
coupée la voiture de maman
nous sommes stupéfaits longtemps nous
avons attendu que ton genou plie avec
crainte devant nous qui pensions être
ton légitime loi si nous le sommes
comment déjà les ont-ils oublié que
londres plaintif en âge un autre
personne
bonjour messieurs s'avérer continuons à
marcher les compos cogner clamé le
shakespeare en rase campagne en plein
d'avancées du shakespeare
que peut-on d'éclat mais d'autres
s'étaient introduites chez coop il veut
monter les trois serres les trois soeurs
je vois pas quel rôle peut jouer
la soeur aînée vous feriez mieux de
réfléchir à ce que vous allez dire à
maman pour sa voiture les voilà son
regard vous devez mourir de faim vous
avez trouvé à manger en france je vous
ai gardé quelque chose de froid j'avais
toi il ya longtemps que vous êtes comme
ça au moins les nouveaux thèmes un
ballet laver à l'eau chaude entre mois à
les brosser ongles jaune revient et des
terribles
montre encore on dirait que c'est du
cambouis du corps maintenant c'est la
terre maman camille ma voiture dans un
garage
oui part d'ennuis non non non non cadeau
de ma voiture tombe comme une horloge
depuis 30 ans bon moi je me la rive oui
et moi aussi
toi tu n'es jamais là dans les coups
durs
vous lui avez dit de lui dire toi même
puisque tu es si mal un jeu peut
commencer
oui mon petit
ah ah
[Musique]
accès
on peut s'arrêter si tu veux tu vois
allez
non
où
à
[Musique]
e
les photos
bon tu as bien compris quand tu fais les
pubs le stade et le commissariat central
de police
[Musique]
capa ben oui il s'agit bien des frères
kavanagh shawn et yann ancien deuxième
ligne de notre équipe de rugby que vous
vouliez savoir leur adresse oui c'est
pour un ami un ami oui vraiment qu'est
la vie comment s'appelle cette amie âge
nationalité race sexe
objet de la visite en irlande adresse
date de naissance prénom et nom des
parents de votre ami je sais rien il en
sait rien bonjour bonjour excusez moi et
qui pourrait me donner des
renseignements sur ces deux joueurs de
rugby
vous devriez voir deux premiers étages
merci beaucoup
nous aurons le plaisir de vous voir
bientôt à dublin madame aurait
probablement la semaine prochaine
vous pensez que maroc sera prêt mais si
vous et qu'il restait seulement deux
jours depuis vous l'emportez j'ai bien
travaillé je suis arrivé ce matin et je
suis obligé de repartir par l'ozone de
ce soir et aurait perdu des chemins fait
quelques heures et comment va votre mari
très bien réussi bon alors à jeudi
prochain pâti à jeudi aimant bons
souvenirs à monsieur henri d'accord
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
à
oh
merci
tu as vu les sourires
je te signale effectivement
baird a man show c'est dégoûtant avec
tango in qui est pas trop mal est déjà
prise non non ça c'est pas le tout il
faut retrouver leur adresse battant
régulièrement compte à leur nom se doit
pas être très difficile et dont j'étais
comme une cabane à toi dans ce pays d'à
peu près 3000
oui mais ce ne sont pas tous des
internationaux de rugby league cavanna
que vous cherchez habite dans le kerry à
3h de cork
ils ont une ferme près d'un petit port à
limoux d'année la famille kavala se
compose de saint frères joe et par ordre
d'âge des croix saint yan patrick
michaels et hommes ils ont une soeur
spring
elle est charmante elle a une boutique
où l'on tisse des trucs
nous voulons très des bijoux fantaisie
de l'artisanat de luxe si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire quand les garçons ne
travaille pas l'affirmer joue au rugby
je m'appelle cora on va aller je suis
française
j'ai épousé anne irlandais peter nous
tenons le pop de bayrou devenu
maintenant je peux vous poser une
question
voulant voler quoi au canada
quand on y vient non pourquoi
parce qu'aujourd'hui je suis le roi
arthur et toi tu as merlin l'enchanteur
oui on c'est chouette john thys et
pourquoi tu es mon copain oui parce que
je suis ton voisin mon père loup les
terres de la famille cabana et s'occupe
de ses chevaux non tu es mon copain
parce que tu es prêt à croire tout ce
que je te dis voilà au allez viens on va
au lac
[Musique]
il
mon père m'a défendu de m'approcher du
lac
pourquoi et dès que je peux me noyer
d'aussi qu'il vient des crocodiles près
ce qu'il t'a dit ça le matin en après
midi nous le soir après sa bière oui les
terribles du coprah need you peut-être
les deux lectra pas ville et on perd
qu'est ce qu'il te dis lui jamais tu
parle de lui pour quoi
puisque anthony anthony ya vite ma mère
pour j aie
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à paris à la fin d'un match de rugby
le reporter photographe reese bardol est
tabassé par les frères cavale
furieux il décide de se venger et pas
pour l'irlande avec paulo son assistant
[Musique]
à dublin
il se souvient avoir aimé disons plutôt
le mannequin vedette d'un défilé de
couture spring cabana
une nuit d'amour vite oublié c'est elle
qui s'est rappelé à mes bons souvenirs
aux le truc classique seulement un
message à lagence trois mois je suis
enceinte c'était vrai et on en veux tu
que je sache si on fait envoyé en
reportage au congo à mon retour il y
avait d'autres lettres d'elle tu les as
lu non banif asie après j'en ai ouvert
une paire médias elle venait de
l'ambassade
elle voulait que je reconnaisse son
enfant une obsession j'avais dû
reconnaître tous les enfants qu'on m'a
attribué mais il était vierge tu me le
dis toi même et avant moi peut-être mais
après c'est tout des menteuses
ça commence dans la passion et ça finit
dans la layette non mais tu vois en
train de changer un nourrisson 1 et ton
père qu'est ce qu'il te dis lui jamais
tu parle de lui pourquoi puisqu'il est
aussi le maire faut que j'y aille
bon ça va rentrer maintenant on est
d'accord
alejo
c'est bien la pression c'est petit niort
hogan ne doit pas être loin
prenez le voilà
ils sont complètement cinglé franchement
vous voyez spring épousé un sédatif
je te prie de ne pas se mêler des
affaires de notre soeur ont dit qu'ils
vont se décider à faire leur demande
officielle cette semaine est plutôt
inquiétant quelqu'un doit entrer dans
notre famille
en épousant notre soeur ce n'est pas à
spring de prendre la décision
mia papa ya maman c'est à moi bonjour
hiesinger salutations c'est une belle
journée
oui superbe et comment se portent vos
volaille très bien il faut moutons au
merveilleusement merci pour eux
au bonjour mademoiselle cabana bonjour s
league
bonjour mademoiselle k naan bonjour
monsieur organes je suis venu vous
acheter quelques unes de vos étoffe
merveilleuse et vous avez puisé tout mon
stock
moi je voudrais jeter un coup d'oeil sur
vos bijoux colliers boucles d'oreilles
broches brasse
oui oui oui moi aussi je me voir aussi
ses ravissants coupons de tissu avec ses
merveilleuses couleurs
mais cette bonne odeur de pure laine oui
est ce que je veux dire mademoiselle
canada ça rappelle nicole les connexions
est ce que tu crois qu'il va pouvoir se
décider à épouser un season
je trouve ces organes et saul singer
trop laid trop vive bien sûr le seul que
tu trouves beauce et patrick cabana mais
il faut aussi penser à la sécurité
moi ce que je vois c'est que spring est
obligé d'élever le petit anthony tout
seul et qu'elle ne peut pas rester mère
célibataire toute sa vie mais anthony à
10 ans maintenant je crois que le plus
dur est fait quant à t elle allusion à
propos de patrick kavanagh sache que je
me soucie fort peu de lui c'est ni mari
ni voilà pas laisser les filles spring
je voudrais vous dire à un mot en
particulier et pour nos cuisines guerre
est occupé en toute loyauté spring il
faut que je vous prévienne il y a
hier après midi j'ai demandé un
rendez-vous à madame votre mère à ma
mère
votre mère madame kavanagh vous avez
besoin de discuter avec elle et oui au
sujet de quoi c'est quelque chose que je
ne peux pas dire
pas encore les les règles officielles
exige que madame votre mère soit la
première personne à être au courant vous
voulez donc parlé à ma mère
officiellement à votre mère
officiellement et aussi à monsieur votre
père j'aimais déjà beaucoup trop dit
swing je serais bref ce prix bien plus
que ce grotesque éleveur de moutons dont
la vue me donne la nausée
je supporte très difficilement de le
voir vous tourner autour et hier matin
j'ai pris une décision de la plus haute
importance je me suis permis de
solliciter quelques longs d'entretien
particulier auprès de monsieur votre
pied magique il je ne peux vous en dire
plus pour le moment
vous savez ma vie est en jeu
vous vous comprenez ma vie mme fortune
et volaille et sentiments surtout ne
m'en veuillez pas je dois me taire mais
je suis tellement bouleversée ouais mon
coup de fer 6 ou comprendre et vous
comprendrez plus tard je veux tous vous
acheter les bijoux les étoffes la
boutique les chapeaux tout je vais tous
vous achetez un spring ne l'écouté pas
je prends l'ensemble des stocks et je
pèse le double
et
c'est la page c'est pas assez solide
pour maman avant on trouve mais pas mal
bon bilan
choix à et regardez celle là là haut non
pas une camionnette
celle là elle est belle oui mais elle
doit être trop cher a dit oui
[Musique]
avez vous un stock une très belle
voiture neuve c'est pour offrir pour
offrir voyons je ne voudrais pas qu'il y
ait de malentendu entre nous mais vous
avez dit 9,9 une belle voiture la plus
belle voiture que vous ayez voile alors
j'ai un monsieur combien 15 mai livre
une affaire je trouve ce modèle un peu
trop voyant pour maman - vous n'avez
rien de plus petits connaissez notre
mère elle déteste attirer l'attention
alors soyons plus clair combien est-ce
que vous voulez mettre du sens de 100
livres alors au revoir messieurs pour ce
prix je les ai même pas une bicyclette
est regardée on dirait la voiture de
maman
voyons messieurs vous n'avez pas
l'intention d'offrir cette ruine à votre
mère pourquoi elle met pas à vendre
j'ai emmené messieurs tout est à vendre
bon près combien je vous fais un prix
d'ami 800 livres
allez venez on s'en va 700 livres 200
livres 300 livres et marché conclut
voulant lever 250 livres et on vous en
débarrasser même vous donner sens au
comptant laissez-moi voir l'argent
j'ai pris sur moi là il y en a 40 et 20
l5
et voilà le compte alors messieurs je
m'incline marchés conclus et sur combien
de mois voulez vous qu'on répartisse les
paiements 12 mois 24 mois dans mon
bureau messieurs nous allons régler les
petites formations
toutes les banlieues en année une autre
bague serveurs cisco
j'adore l'avion de transpole ont pendant
une demi-heure avant moi avez vous
connais votre mari au loup on arrive au
même moment devant une sculpture
égyptienne une grosse femme entourée de
serpents plusieurs années après notre
mariage en a reparlé la scène est bon
navet paris pour la même chose en
véritable manne entendu trop tard
rejoindra regrette rien c'est un enfant
qui torée mois nous n'avons pas eu
d'enfants non
et vous vous avez des enfants 9 et vous
balancer
c'est exactement votre reportage au la
vie quotidienne des joueurs de rugby
leur entourage familial enfin voyez ce
genre de truc l'hérault hors du stade
et après les cabanes à lire et voir qui
a tous les autres d'ailleurs je
préférais que vous ne prévoyez pas les
cabanes à notre arrivée
oui si ça convient pour eux ils sont pas
naturels et nous ce qu'on voudrait c'est
sûr prendre sur le vif pas un impôt sur
le vif
ça c'est le mot dites-leur commence mais
pour quelqu'un d'autre
big enough
ratti nas c'est un phénomène il est fou
de théâtre il vous montre les trois
soeurs de tchekhov pour les pêcheurs du
village s'appelle comment déjà votre
journal ce point journal c'est une
agence lagence alpha et on envoie nos
reportages à tous les magazines du monde
entier et textes et photos j'aurais
adoré être une journaliste
ça doit être passionnant et des hauts et
des bas
[Musique]
c'est notre premier voyage en irlande
absolument le premier
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur aulas dit oui où est
votre divine épouse m'a divine épouse
état du blâme sur casillas
comment pouvez vous laisser partir une
aussi merveilleuse créature les
merveilleuses créatures ne demande
jamais la permission
elle s'entend vous ne prendrez pas si je
vous dis que je viens justement de
composer une horde en son honneur
non monsieur katina je ne prendrait pas
ombrage ne l'ont pas du tout c'est
encore un peu tôt pour moi et je suis en
plein dedans mais compte figurer de cora
m'inspire beaucoup
peut-être parce qu'elle vient de france
et que la france autant que les landes
et le pays des poètes c'est des fous
mesure les lie monsieur craintes tenaces
je vais souvent à paris et entre nous et
j'y rencontre plus de singles et que
deux poètes bon qu'est-ce que je vous
sers on revient du tout j'aurais voulu
vous liront pas n se colle au écoutez
j'ai une très bonne idée
vous ne voulez pas qu'on attende que
correspond au revenu et bien vous
pourrez lire votre poème en public ici
au bar les clients adorent tout ce que
vous faites à à propos je voulais vous
demander où en est votre bateau ou en
toujours en cale sèche on attend encore
une pièce pour le gouvernant qui doit
venir de grèce il ya combien de temps
que vous êtes échoué ici huit ans une
rafale m'a fait lancer sur les rochers
de ben ali ou dany et josé les semaines
sont passées au milieu du peuple qui m'a
accueillie comme un ami voyons alors ce
point non non il vaut mieux attendre ce
soir monsieur katyn à tous nos clients
amateurs d'art pourront vous entendre ça
va être formidable fabuleux
[Musique]
macif it
à 6 pi voyez pas quelque chose
et puis dégagé ne restez pas ces saletés
tu feras ne marche plus
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les plus jeunes ne va pas chômer
qu'est ce que vous attendez feignant
poussé mois arrive
allez les gars on y va et pousser et
pousser plus fort tu veux bien fermé
konan je me sauve anthony m'attends à la
maison je te comprends noté gentil
gémeaux vélo n'oublie pas de veste
crochet jeu prime ni non bien est ce
qu'il y a j'étais en train de penser à
ces deux rigolos qui de poursuivre je
les trouve grotesque
il ne faut pas cracher sur la clientèle
mon cher ces deux crétins suge pas mal
de ce qu'on fabrique ici tu sais
parfaitement qui ne viennent que parce
que tu es là tant qu'ils font marcher
mon commerce
je ne supporte plus n'oublie pas le
crochet ne t'inquiète pas ça au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hogan août singer des plus riches
éleveurs d'irlande
ils viennent en même temps ah si
seulement spring voulaient y mettre un
peu du sien
l'avez-vous mise au courant il n'est pas
question de parler à spring tant que
nous n'avons pas entendu officiellement
ce que ces messieurs la nuit mais le
faux portant anthony va bientôt avoir
dix ans et il est temps pour sa mère de
prendre mari at-elle jamais marqué une
préférence pour l'axé 2 oignons
pas à ma connaissance et toi est bonne
je ne m'en a jamais parlé
ils lui font pourtant la cour depuis
cinq ans bon maman tu peux devenir d'or
une minute
pourquoi faire mon dieu nous avons une
surprise pour maman vous êtes tous vous
lancez une voiture était bien à celle où
l'autre il aurait fallu la changer maman
c'est vrai alors pourquoi pas
aujourd'hui on a eu un mal fou pour la
dénicher mais hélas combien de chevaux
il refuse de dévoiler la puissance
considérable enclos rory comme chez rock
je ne sais comment vous remercier thor
ça me touche vraiment bon willow l'autre
eh bien oui ma bonne vieille voiture qui
ne m'a jamais trahi soit l'autre
devenait trop dangereuse
maurice allais fin commencé à lâcher
alors j'espère qu'on vous a fait une
bonne reprise nous avons fait une
affaire là ça oui pratiquement un
échange standard
je peux l'essayer bien sûr nos meilleurs
efforts maman tu passes par là nous
avons déroulé le tapis rouge pour toi tu
y ailles ouvre la porte
[Applaudissements]
les clés maman il ya une petite
amélioration par rapport à l'ancienne
thual embrayage automatique qui
signifient il n'y a plus que deux
pédales comme une bicyclette une panne
accélérateur et l'autre pour le frein
tout ce que tu as à faire c'est freiner
et accélérer n'a pas besoin de toucher à
autre chose la voiture réfléchi pour toi
si à toi de jouer maman faire l'essai
des mares nous tenir en mairie mairie
soit très prudente
je fais juste un petit tour aux mamans
contacter ici dont la clé alors
maintenant appuyé sur l'accélérateur
tout doucement tout au tout doucement
elle est très nerveuse une caresse juste
une caresse seulement une caresse
voilà
les mamans 13,7 à gauche la [ __ ] la
[ __ ] de gauche
oh
ps je t'en prie nick swisher
aulas
la plaque sera au mans accroché pour
passe haute vitesse
bracken venait de moi alors
aidez moi
papa
vous avez fait sentir mais vous verrez
comment vas tu étais déjà fait quoi
tamar est cette saloperie de bompas mon
sens elle va finir par nous dans l'est
j'ai beau me dire je vais lâcher
je ne peux pas me passer
ça va bien j'espère je crois que je
préférais l'ancien j'ai pas fumer c'est
servir au mieux le monsieur arthur au
miel
le mardi c'est toujours au miel mais
petit y allait d'un gamin je dis citron
vert vendredi sauge fraîche
samedi la bande et puis l'a10 et du
romarin et le dimanche qu'est ce que
c'est le dimanche c'est le jour du
seigneur monsieur arthur aucun parfum
juste une légère touche de vinaigre de
vinaigre mais quelle idée
dites-moi plusieurs états répondez-moi
vite sans réfléchir dit oui ou non s'il
vous plaît à quel propos monsieur pas
touché dit
vous répondez sans réfléchir et bien
sans réfléchir
non non pourquoi non je dis toujours non
c'est une habitude il ya des tas ma
pauvre violetta heureux le comprendrai
jamais rien à l'amour et apportez moi ma
chemise blanche et dépêchez vous oui
mais c'est à retenir
ritz au maire pourquoi tous ces chapeaux
vous n'avez qu'une seule tête erreurs
mais j'ai perdu la tête
en tout cas je n'en suis plus le maître
juge m
voudriez vous être assez gentil pour
répéter le mot que vous venez d'utiliser
je vais de ce pas demandé la main de
celle que j'aime assez pas sans avoir
consulté votre mère est bien 55 ans j'ai
pensé que je n'avais plus besoin de
votre consentement nous du vivant de ce
monsieur votre père jamais vous n'auriez
osé me parlé sur un ton aussi insolent
que dieu ait son âme r le célibat
commence à me peser
je souhaite à mériter je voudrais
prendre femme je vais m'y employer le
nom de cette misérable kavanagh quelques
havana et havana de bali moudre vers ces
brutes qui joue au ballon
je préférerais disparaître que de voir
une fille mère et son patin s'introduire
dans la famille ou de signes très bien
mer disparaissait tôt
[Musique]
combien de kilomètres nous de cork
gore qu il ya les avions tous les jours
paris autrefois j'étais comme lui lors
de paris prenne sa lutte blague
aujourd'hui j'ai tout faux que trois
jours lui mais j'aimerais puis ensuite
vous comprenez où ces différents modes
variés disions que les jeunes veulent
mari peter
alors je m'absente il s'en aperçoit même
pas alors j'ai
de winne qui est avec moi de françaises
et de français je vois ce sont des
clients comme les autres ils vont nouer
les deux chambres inoccupées duo après
la défaite de samedi les français sont
plutôt mal vu dans la région il pourrait
y avoir des représailles joue pas au
rugby surtout les journalistes ils
viennent spécialement de paris pour
rencontrer trappe seen as grâce à lui
banimmo l'homme avait devenir célèbre
pour son torchon
je vais te présenter je vous attendrai
cuisine vient mon mari chris pour
longtemps assistant
je vais désinstaller ils ont pas mal du
tout la douche ne marche plus il reste
lavabo il est bouché le lavabo ça fait
rien je vais leur montrer la chambre et
je redescends suivez moi mais si c'est
pas possible
écoute moi écoute moi c'est un endroit
très calme très reposent ces chambres ne
sont pas en état d'être loué les photos
que je ne laissais pas du voyage d'un
mois
je pensais qu'il était pas jaloux des
français seulement
et bien je vous la 5 minute
installez-vous je revienne merci a lot
more in facilement la firme de kavanagh
s'il vous plaît
29 livres pour ça
spring et là je pourrai lui parler merci
spring ne parle pas ne dit rien de winne
qui est avec moi
le salon qui t'a fait un enfant
oui christophe bardol le père d'anthony
unies cinu seigneur bénissez en même
temps ces sédiments portrait libéralités
nous accorde pas situer notre seigneur
oui mais si on perd je peux poser une
question ou initier les courtes
pourquoi on dit la prière avant de
manger au lieu de la faire après ce
serait bien plus logique quand on en est
là bien tu toi et mange je te trouve pas
est ce que tu es malade
messieurs silence s'il vous plaît
c'est à la demande expresse de pîtres
aurélie notre hôte ici présents merci
merci je vais avoir le plaisir de vous
lire à tous un poème je viens de
composer en l'honneur de son épouse
la divine madame colle à oreille précise
qu'il s'agit des très courts
ouais
une fois ma lecture d'achever une
tournée de bière dans la salle ni à tous
une tournée crac pur joyau de métal sous
des douches veut de leyme ses yeux plein
voltigeant tovo imprévisible ses mains
on va aussi avoir droit aux pieds à
bouche au menton oui c'est un inventaire
va y passer la nuit
c'est une soif tiendront pas le coup
moi je te le dis et yeux de feu des
longs doigts de fée la saison et
irlandais
la ville marine explosait dans ses
droits si elle devait contenir de notre
divine colle à la peau t
merci beaucoup ce poème est très beau
venir
ces messieurs de la presse vous attend
[Applaudissements]
ainsi notre célèbre poète homère trapped
in à christophe bardol de la presse
internationale chanter bonjour bonjour
son assistant sont venus spécialement
ici pour votre prochain spectacle droit
c'est oui s'il voulait imprimer
qu'est ce que vous voulez une bouteille
de whisky c'est pas très bien sur le
compte de qui sur le mien quant à votre
oreille mais formidable mon assistant a
particulièrement apprécié quand vous
êtes gentil ah non mais vraiment joyce
mallarmé milton sa trompette il vous a
suffi de quatre revers pour les reléguer
leur propre place et comment et moi mon
vieux vous connaissez les kavanagh
félicitations merci merci
les carabins soyez le voyez vous jusqu'à
présent la conception scénique des trois
soeurs a toujours été conventionnel ce
que je voudrais où est ce qu'ils aient
dit écoute pour notre ennui monsieur
praline à katsina au maire christina qui
suppose qu'ils habitent dans une sphère
et dans une ferme exactement vous
comprenez
chistine tchekhov est victime d'une
trahison pire d'un malentendu
c'est loin d'ici monsieur ries mathias
coccinelle
katsina
[Musique]
elle
quoi
c'est votre poème qui l'ancien nocifs
non c'est parce que colas ne vous a pas
facturer la bouteille
vous
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
b
ses copains c'est chez coop ça j'en
conviens mais les cabanes à quelque
chose et tout à fait entre nous se sont
creusées musculaire de groupuscules r
savez-vous ce qu'on trouvait dans la
pâte sans louvain la tête un ballon
dégonflé je vous aime bien vos yeux
ballin a semé le sida c'est monsieur
ries ma tournée oui
[Applaudissements]
j'apprécie votre générosité
je suis touché par leur dette je suis
très touché mais laissez-moi vous dire
comment ce que montre que j'ai pris à
percer notre défense pour troisième
essai il faut lire la vérité il faut
dire la vérité il était en jeu
ouais
non monsieur je n'ai pas parce qu'ils
paient tollé que je loue à beaucaire ma
conscience me brige à parler serait le
succès vrai j'ai tout ce que c'est vrai
il est contraire
[Musique]
ouais
payer tes frères tout le monde au
tchèque est beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est juste un bon exercice de mêlée
yann avec moi vous trois ensembles
j'aime beaucoup trop pour les enfants
ce n'est pas normal qu'à 3 vous
n'arriviez pas à faire reculer de
vétérans comme nous c'est pas
[Musique]
exercice dollars
jda salue la bon tu veux pas que l'on
trouvait à plus gros ouais 1 et 3
[Musique]
un tour du monde thomas lanning tienne
à l'école
vous allez chez les cabanes à sa suite à
chris de décider possible qu'on aille y
faire une petite reconnaissance
mais auparavant on a promis à cranach de
passer chez lui il nous attend à bord de
son vous verrez c'est un très beau
bateau bon
[Musique]
et oui bah ça laisse aussi des cafés
- claude bez un courant ici j'en ai
marre de ce pays bon allez on laisse
tomber on fout quoi ok y'a nation à une
heure non non non actionnaire fort des
partis aux abords tu préparais caméras
d'une main dans le sac à main c'est de
me trouver une paire de jumelles
derniers exercices est venu dépêchez
vous ça va bon à mon commandement telle
avancée assez
[Musique]
[Rires]
bien joué les gars on ne peut pas battre
à cheval irlande
moi les enfants ça vient au monde comme
les poulains exactement alors
logiquement on devrait pouvoir nourrir
les bébés avec du foie je t'avais
données du foie lorsque tu es bd qui
auraient de grandes oreilles et tu
marcherait à quatre pattes et au lieu de
parler tu te mettrai à hennir maman
voilà cora
[Musique]
lure
bien savoir qui membres à la vie de la
mangue nos professeurs d'histoire de
france ô toi t'as pas réviser ses leçons
non pourquoi je t'ai pas au mieux de ma
forme hier soir j'avais pas envie de
travailler
salut au revoir à tout à l'heure
d'accord tu devrais aller jouer avec le
poney va voir s'il n est pas j'ai
compris c'est le temps des secrets
[Musique]
m
a osé revenir maintenant temps que je
vais à la maison je peux contrôler la
situation
en tout cas essayer de manoeuvrer pour
éviter le pire mais justement je veux le
pire je vais laisser mes frères
s'occuper de lui ils vont le tuer je
vais tout de même pas provoquer le
meurtre du père de son enfant
si je vais le faire c'est la shdm a
laissé tomber il m'a laissé me
débrouiller avec ma famille avec le
village il n'a pas répondu une seule
fois mais l'être pas à moyen comme si je
n'avais jamais existé
je sais pas ce qu'il va faire en irlande
et puisqu'il est assez fou pour remettre
les pieds ici il va me le payer
écoute je ne veux plus jamais le revoir
tu m'entends même pas son cadavre
quand mes frères se sont amusés en faire
de la viande hachée avant avec une
maison comment s'amuser à fabas viande
hachée avec toi si tu te mets pas tes
leçons d'histoire de france
immédiatement
je veux que tu me réussit sans se
tromper
les noms de tous les rois de france
on ramène cette immense pendant cinq
minutes
[Musique]
et quand tu t'arrêtes on n'a pas fini je
meurs de faim
oh oui moi aussi mais qu'est ce qui se
passe à la maison pour que l'on ne veut
pas qu'on rentre avant 10 heures
j'en sais rien et m'a pas fait confiance
eh bien je crois qu'il doit avoir de la
visite
quel genre de visite maintenant on se
tait et on prend le travail et je n'ai
même pas eu la moindre grippe depuis 30
ans madame kavanagh en fait si vous
voulez jeter un coup d'oeil sur mes
certificats médicaux
[Musique]
fini
ma fille est et ceci est mon relevé
bancaire de ce mois ci bien qu'ils
attaquent peut on me l'a remis hier
à
je suis ravi de voir l'excellence de
votre état de santé ainsi que
l'importance de votre compte en banque
monsieur hogan votre visite est pour
nous un plaisir et un honneur
je dois vous avouer toutefois que nous
avons quelques difficultés en comprendre
le sens madame kamana le cas banal
j'ai eu l'immense honneur de vous
demander officiellement votre fille en
mariage je te trouve trop modèle
tu as fait des progrès extraordinaires
c'est un jour tu veux en france on va te
prendre pour un vrai petit français tu
parles écoute il ya encore très peu de
temps tu butaient sur les noms les plus
tu te rappelles par versailles le louvre
napoléon les vas-y à tête
versailles le louvre napoléon et mon
père quel est son nom tu le connais toi
[Musique]
ah voilà ta mère je te rends ton petit
génie si ça continue c'est lui qui va me
donner des leçons tu verras il m'a
demandé le nom de son père je te laisse
répondre je n'ai pas su qu'on lui dit
[Musique]
elle a vanté chery ça rentre et sort de
france puis-je ajouter que ma mère lady
car à une singer connaît le véritable
but de ma visite
malgré certaines réserves qui est tout à
fait compréhensible chez une dame de son
âge elle ne tardera certainement pas à
l'approuver officiellement quel est le
véritable but de votre visite monsieur
une single
ah oui madame kah walla monsieur
kavanagh j'ai le plaisir de vous
demander irrévocablement est
officiellement mademoiselle votre fille
en mariage
[Musique]
et
le
[Musique]
c'est pas possible yassir dans la région
qu'est ce que c'est que ça les cavs à
nos bambins
je veux bien écrit ça prend un premier
galop mais acer va sacrer je te le dis
tu paies ce qu'ont bien mais c'est pas
le poids qui compte c'est la envie de
détruire
ils sont cinq tu agis vite tu peux en
mettre deux ou trois immédiatement hors
de combat
moi je m'occupe des deux autres mais
alors c'est de l'ag veut ldh
s'il s'en servent mais aussi crise et
sur le plan 4o fallait pas venir
bon bah quand tu voudras
[Musique]
et si ce jeudi quand tu voudras
si on rentre est maintenant maman n'ont
pas tout de suite ta grand-mère à de la
visite faut pas la déranger mon chéri tu
sais de john le même je les connais
monsieur arthur hogan et monsieur
fritzinger tu les as vu cent fois
galoper à cheval ces deux vieux schnock
pourtant central a quand même c'est rien
paul simon ce qu'ils veulent ils vaquent
t'épouser a tout sorti ce genre de
nouvelles penny la dia la mère de john
et la mère de john aime bien son père et
john a tout entendu m'a répété je n'en
sais rien nous allons la prendre par
grands-pères et grands-mères comme tu
peux voir je n'ai pas si c'est la
conversation
ces deux là ils ont un droit de culot
vouloir épouser ma mère quand tu entends
des oncles ils doivent se faire les
muscles bien on va les rejoindre
qu'est-ce que tu regardes et tu ris je
te parle on va faire
mais dis moi ce que tu vois groupe de
fermiers et thierry avec des faux alors
on y va on n'y va pas non pas maintenant
t20 réglerons nos comptes demain
[Musique]
et
à
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]